nominees for performance by an actress  in a leading role are Jane Fonda in the  morning after [ __ ] Spacek and crimes of  the heart Kathleen Turner  marlee matlin children of a lesser God  Sigourney Weaver  and the winner is Marlee Matlin  I am I just want to thank a lot of  people aya  to tell you the truth I didn't prepare  for this speech but I definitely want to  thank the Academy and its members and I  want to thank all those special people  in the film and I can name them Randa  Hannes Patrick Palmer the entire cast  and crew and particularly William Hurt  for his great support and love in this  film and I want to thank my mother and  father Eric Marc Gloria Zachary and Liz  they're here tonight with me and I just  want to thank all of you I love you